foreign
[Applause]
ers
boys your mother is dead
she died because you sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind
you know my business yes
power is about strength
if you show weakness
you will give our enemies an opening
shot
foreign
[Music]
death in the face and for the first time
I saw my true self
tell me about this Hunter
they say he uses a connection with
animals to track his prey
once you're on his list
there's only one way off the six of us
and only one of you there's six of you
now
[Music]
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the world
I take it out
[Music]
thank you
thank yous you were exactly like our
father just another man hunting for a
trophy
we're murderers
isn't that what he taught us
we don't get to do that to me anymore
Mr techlin
good
where's Mr tagley oh you're standing in
him
you're a goddamn lunatic oh you just
figure that out now
foreign
[Music]
animal in each one of us don't you want
to know why they call me the rhino
foreign